[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes le vendredi
18 novembre bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 hebdo une émission pour
revenir sur l'actualité de la semaine
voici les titres elle des bénéficiaires
du rsa dans les collèges yvelinois c'est
la nouvelle initiative portée par le
département objectif insertion et
formation des personnes concernées nous
avons suivi l'un d'entre eux c'est un
projet lancé en 1998 semble enfin
avancer la enfouissement partiel de la
nationale 10 à trappes pour parler
notamment de cette actualité guy
malandain le maire de la ville est notre
invité fil rouge durant une demi-heure
dans le reste de l'actualité enfin nous
reviendrons sur la venue de françois
hollande dans les yvelines pour le
lancement du chantier ariane 6 ou encore
l'élection du nouveau maire à guyancourt
après la démission de françois deux
lignes mais on ouvre ce journal avec le
départ hier des derniers migrants qui
était installée depuis début novembre
dans la salle des fêtes de mort pas
comme prévu initialement les dizaines de
personnes arrivées après le
démantèlement d'un campement parisiens
ne seront restées que deux semaines
selon des informations du journal le
parisien les personnes qui étaient
encore présentes à maurepas récemment
ont été redirigés vers d'autres lieux
d'accueil dans les yvelines
dans un autre registre maintenant le
département des yvelines propose depuis
cette année à des bénéficiaires du rsa
d'être embauchées en contrats aidés dans
les 116 collège et yvelinois un
dispositif pour permettre l'insertion et
la formation des concernés une autre
journaliste nicolas landry a pu
rencontrer l'un d'entre eux eric à
grappin est agent polyvalent au collège
ariana à guyancourt reportage
à 32 ans erica grappin est en contrat
unique d'insertion au collège ariane de
guyancourt après deux mois de chômage
elle a accepté une proposition de pôle
emploi agent polyvalent au service
général et à la restauration scolaire
pour ce contrat aidé de 30 heures par
semaine sur un an erika gagnent un
revenu de 880 euros par mois en
complément du rsa je vais chercher mon
chariot je pars dans mes classes je fais
les tableaux je lave les tables ce qui
est souvent des écritures ou de la colle
après je passe un coup sur le sol
après j'aimerais bien pouvoir rester
dans un établissement scolaire parce que
c'est quelque chose qui me plaît
travailler dans un établissement
scolaire qui fait partie du département
ou de la région ou même des mairies et
tout le département embauché 258
bénéficiaires du rsa en contrats aidés
dans les collèges yvelinois depuis la
rentrée 2016 l'état le département et
pôle emploi collaborent sur ce
dispositif à travers le financement et
la formation par exemple sur 7 258
contrat il y à déjà 65 personnes qui
sont en formation hygiène qui leur
donnera des d un savoir faire
particulier au delà de ce contrat l'idée
ce n'est pas de transformer tous les
bénéficiaires du rsa en futurs agents de
la fonction publique
l'idée c'est de les mettre dans un
parcours d'employabilité
l'idée c'est de travailler au plus près
à votre pôle emploi pour pour les
compétences de départ et la capacité de
formation pour qu'ils aient un avenir
professionnel de dans ou en dehors de la
collectivité locale au 30 octobre 2016
le département comptabilise 24000 250
bénéficiaires du rsa 35 % ont entre 25
et 34 ans
[Musique]
dans l'actualité locale cette semaine
l'avancée d'un projet de presque 20 ans
à trappes l'enfouissement partiel de la
n10 le conseil municipal de la ville
s'est réuni mercredi soir pour voter le
protocole financier entre les différents
partis une réunion est d'ailleurs prévue
d'ici quelques jours entre les acteurs
du projet reportage
1998 2000 16 18 ans 18 ans que le projet
d'enfouissement de la nationale 10
attrapés dans les cartons un enjeu
majeur pour la mairie et qui semble
enfin avancer les élus municipaux ont
validé hier mercredi 16 novembre le
protocole financier entre les différents
partis état région département
agglomération et communes on a fait un
conseil municipal exceptionnel de façon
à être prêt pour le les jours qui
viennent ou normalement avec l'état le
conseil régional le conseil
départemental la communauté
d'agglomération et la ville on doit
signer le contrat de financement
convient de 2 votée à l'unanimité moins
une voix ce conseil municipal
selon le pacte financier voté hier le
projet du recouvrement partiel de la n
10 devrait coûter 95,1 millions d'euros
dont 42 à la charge de l'état très
ennemis pour l'agglomération et 2 pour
la commune de trappes une répartition
voté par l'opposition de droite là pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de débat
particulier sur sur ce point là il
pourrait y en avoir plus tard à propos
du projet proprement dit qui nous pose
quelques questions en termes de
désengorgement réel de la ville en
moyenne 80 mille véhicules passent tous
les jours sur la nationale 10 au niveau
de trappes il y a donc urgence pour les
habitants même si le projet présenté
hier ne fait pas l'unanimité 81 90 mille
voitures par jour enfin voitures et
camions et le bruit la pollution et on
peut pas on peut pas laisser une ville
comme ça on est dépassé au visionnage se
rappeler qu'on est tous d'accord qu'il
ya un problème mais la solution que nous
propose elle ne nous satisfait pas une
enquête publique est organisée jusqu'au
17 décembre en mairie de trappes les
travaux devraient débuter en 2018 pour
une mise en service espérée en 2021 soit
23 un an après le lancement du projet
et pour évoquer le sujet guy malandain
maire ps de la ville qu'on a vu
d'ailleurs dans le sujet nous a rejoint
bonsoir bonsoir à vous même soir à tous
aux auditeurs et était intéressé par
votre télévision locale bravo à vous
pour ce qui vous fait alors que je vous
demande un est ce qu'on peut dire enfin
après après ce sujet que ça y est c'est
parti l'enfouissement de la n10 parce
que plusieurs fois on a évoqué un début
des travaux d'ailleurs on avait nous
aussi diffusé des sujets qui disait
début des travaux en 2016 là on prévoit
un début des travaux 2018 est ce que
vous pouvez dire c'est sûr à 100% 2018
les travaux vont commencer alors c'est
une longue histoire 20 ans voilà les
premiers plans date de
1998 ça il ya eu beaucoup de discussions
beaucoup de projets contradictoires des
confusions avec l'autoroute a12 et
cetera et cetera
aujourd'hui nous avons la chance je le
dis comme ça parce que pour la ville
c'est un projet très important pour sa
situation actuelle des puits pour son
devenir
des avoirs
réussi à conclure des éléments
essentiels comme le projet de
financement chacun y participe en eau au
montant que vous disiez tout à l'heure
il s'agit là de l'enfouissement
du plateau urbain ce qui tous les
aménagements au dessus alors
l'enfouissement et c'est la priorité
notamment de faire d'abord le tandem en
avance à l'état et tout ce qui est
dessus c'est la ville qui est maître
d'ouvragé la sur le dessus la ville mais
entre 12 et 13 mai 13 millions d'euros
qui s'ajoutent aux 2 / sur
l'enfouissement donc aujourd'hui tout le
monde est d'accord sur les montants la
signature doivent au lieu sous
l'autorité de monsieur le préfet de
région qui a oeuvré de façon très très
très efficace et je le salue toujours
parce que la réalité est elle arrêtée
lankais public et étant commencée depuis
hier depuis jeudi 10 septembre jusqu'au
17 décembre au 17 décembre ce qui veut
dire d'ailleurs que le projet peut être
encore changé à la marge selon les
valider les agents du il ya déjà eu de
réponse à votre question mais avant je
rappelle qu'il ya trois ans ou quatre
ans je peux me tromper dans la distance
liste à peu près ça toute la
concertation préalable avec tous les
éléments et avait la maquette qui
avaient été exposées il ya trois quatre
ans autrement dit le socle le
les éléments essentiels de ce projet
sont maintenant figé alors après il y a
il y à l'enquêté publique qui permet à
tous les citoyens qui le souhaitent de
s'exprimer en disant moi je suis
d'accord je suis pas d'accord jouer ceux
ci voudraient cela et ça il le
commissaire les commissaires enquêteurs
puisqu'ils sont deux feront leur rapport
et ils feront des décideront des
obligations ou des recommandations et
les différents partenaires l'état en
particulier puisqu'on est dans cette
phase là dira oui je prends ou non je ne
prends pas ce qui veut dire que l'état
aujourd'hui malgré on sait les échéances
électorales s'est engagée et ça ne va
pas ça ne va plus bouger va investir
l'argent nécessaire si si vous avez un
rendez-vous d'ailleurs bientôt quoi en
quoi va consister ce seront des meufs
qui signe le signature vous êtes
optimiste ça va être signée à écouter
oui je suis assez content au timide je
serai encore plus content quand la
signature sera fait et encore plus
content quand je verrai une pelleteuse
c'est une façon de parler pour les
travaux faits ce qui on en verra
d'autres choses avant avant les
pelleteuses non je crois à très très
sérieusement
l'enfouissement on va appeler comme ça
de la nationale 10 et le plateau urbain
font partie du projet numéro un dans le
contrat de plan état région pour les
années qui existe en ce moment c'est le
projet ni leroy j'aimais chine pour vous
en tant que mère depuis que depuis vous
êtes à la mairie toi je n'avais pas
absolu là il n'y avait pas celui ci mais
aujourd'hui séculier enfin c'est aller
voilà il suffit il suffit de regarder
c'est l'autoroute du sud qui coupe la
ville en deux heures après on peut être
d'accord sur une petite virgule tête
petit aménagement on est toujours
d'accord d'ailleurs quand les choses se
passent chez les autres c'est beaucoup
mieux comme ça mais c'est c'est
l'habitude je suis habitué à ça non
c'est un élément fondamental pour
faire échapper au bruit et à la
pollution le passage de ces 88 véhicules
avec beaucoup de camions et c'est un
élément indispensable pour raccrocher la
ville nous avons une ville de trappes
qui aujourd'hui dans une situation
unique c'est-à-dire 20000 habitants d'un
côté 10000 de l'hôte et on clame il
coupé en deux et 1.2 joie pour rejoindre
tous les éléments essentiels génériques
une dernière précision sur le sujet
l'enquète public c'est jusqu'au 17
décembre en mairie de trappes c'est ça
oui c'est ton mairie de trappes dans
l'ancienne médiathèque rue jean jaurès
dans le reste de l'actualité cette
semaine un déplacement présidentiel
françois hollande était lundi aux
mureaux pour poser le premier la
première pierre d'un autre chantier
celui de d'ariane 6 le nouveau lanceur
européen qui doit permettre la mise en
orbite de satellites pour l'observation
de la terre notamment ariane 6 qui doit
permettre aussi à l'europe de rester
pionnière dans l'aérospatiale comme
l'expliqué le président de la république
est lundi on l'écoutent
aujourd'hui l'industrie spatiale elle
est également soumise à concurrence
et notamment une concurrence
américaine
qui voudraient prendre
à travers des processus qu'on connaît
qu'on ne va pas ici d'écrire mais de l'
avance sur nous donc nous avons le
devoir d'être les meilleurs tout en
acceptant la concurrence et c'est tout
l'objet de l'entreprise asl guy
malandain on va parler avec vous des
hérauts spatiale une petite j'en suis
sûr c'est un sujet qui vous passionne
mais de politique puisque ça bouge
beaucoup ces derniers temps à droite à
gauche on va commencer par votre camp et
l'annoncé cette semaine de la
candidature à la présidentielle
d'emmanuel le maquereau 38 ans quel
regard vous portez sur celui qui se dit
un peu hors système qui se prétend selon
lui d'aller contre le courant classique
de la politique le schéma classique
calendaire vous portez sur sur emmanuel
macron je n'ai pas la butte de de porter
des regards sur les personnes parce que
les personnels sont doubles elle ils ont
toujours des choses inconnues de grande
valeur en elle-même et puis des éléments
extérieurs qui peuvent poser question
est quelquefois faire sourire moi je
suis tout à fait opposé à
ce système de primaires de ce que
j'appelle à lui ne fera pas la primaire
d'ailleurs il se présente bien réussi
pareil c'est dans une ambiance c'est une
ambiance fantastique
ma conviction politique jugé ce prix
depuis longtemps fermement que j'ai
exprimée encore récemment dans une
allocation publique
la vème république et c'est un président
de la république un gouvernement et une
assemblée deux assemblées avec le sénat
un président de la république c'est une
personne qui on qualifie d'homme ou de
femme d'état c'est à dire dont on sait
même si on n'est pas d'accord avec ce
projet on peut dire oui c'est un
président de la république oui c'est une
présente de la république c'est un homme
ou une femme d'état aujourd'hui on a une
panoplie j'allais dire les hongrois de
deux personnes qui qui est ça l'aurait
peut-être devrait s'interroger pour dire
dans la situation de mon pays dans la
situation mondiale dont on connaît la
difficulté les tensions laiterie
missiles et tout l'est vraiment une
époque extrêmement chargé est ce que mon
expérience
et mon savoir ma pensée ma stature fait
face à tout ça et je peux être président
de la république ce que ça vaut pour
emmanuel macron par exemple ça vaut pour
eux emmanuel macron ça vaut ce que ça
vaut pour benoît hamon aussi j'ai envie
se présente à la primaire et qui était
dans votre nom c'est municipale jusqu'à
récemment
je parle pas des personnes munies d
amitié ni des fraternités beaudoin
cerland amis c'est vrai un copain je dis
quelquefois ce gouffre en jambes on voit
la baie après nous sommes nous sommes en
politique
on a lu de gaulle on a eu un mitron on
peut avoir un niveau un peu différent
mais quand même présent
pompidou par exemple je je diversifie
voyez-vous mon regard est ce qu'on va
dire la wii u hollande
je pense que je pense que lon que je
connais bien qui est qui et qui est
quelqu'un de sérieux donne est d'engager
d'avoir envie
ce qu'il avait
comme sarkozy avant d'ailleurs pour moi
là c'est dimension d'homme d'état jeu
qu'il ne la cherchez je sais pas par
moments je dis oui ça y est il l'a
trouvée par moments je me dis non il
s'agit de notre pays il s'agit de notre
république s'agit pas de dupont ou
durand vous voyez ce que je veux
exprimer vous voyez ce qui se passe
l'actualité politique ces hommes
politiques qui se chamaillent tous les
jours quel regard vous portez vous êtes
un peu peiné finalement beaucoup
honnêtement je vous regarde comme ça
enfin parce que je suis navré de ça
quand je vois après on va voir la gauche
qui va qu'il fallait faire les faits
tout mais quand je vois ces personnes
qu'est
qui se battent ils sont copains y
cotisent dans le même parti ils ont été
ensemble dans les mêmes gouvernements il
y en a qui a déjà été présent de la
république on a vu ce qu'il savait faire
vraiment s'il ici on avait été content
la france avait été contente il aura été
réélu ce qui n'est pas le cas il oublie
tout ce qu'il a fait bref
non je m'interroge sur le devenir de mon
pays alors ça peut déranger ce que je
dis mais moi je m'interroge ou et où l
homme d'état qui va aider la france à
faire face aux difficultés économiques à
la pauvreté à nos relations
internationales au nouvelle dimension
européenne à toute l'évolution
mondiale alaska la misère en afrique etc
vous vous interrogez aussi sur l'avenir
de la gauche en france beaucoup
prédisent que la gauche pourrait
disparaître puisque les candidatures
semblent se multiplier mélenchon les
verts le ps qui va voir sa primaire
emmanuel ma peau qui va se présenter est
ce que vous avez peur que la gauche
disparaissent tout simplement du paysage
politique français pendant cinq ans
alors pour moi pour moi qui suis
tout le monde le sait un homme de gauche
militant tranquille of fate rang qu'il
faut dire qu'ils avaient des ambitions
politiques et d'affaires comment on vous
prédisez presqu'un ministère à un moment
on m'a proposé un militaire est
effectivement et mais je n'ai pas le
temps de raconter ça ici et on a proposé
ministère du logement et on va proposer
cet autre chose que j'ai dit non bref
c'est pas
je crois pouvoir dire pour être
synthétique la gauche à dire est ce pas
à disparaîtra pas parce que la gauche
est elle est une histoire l'histoire
d'un peuple d'accord ou pas d'accord la
3 de pareil d'ailleurs un c est une
histoire sociale c'est une histoire
économique c'est une histoire
philosophique ce qui est en difficulté
et j'ai déjà connu ça et je terminerai
par là ce sont les partis politiques les
gens ont plus confiance moi j'ai connu
ça à la fin la fin je suis pas tout
jeune tout le monde le sait à la fin de
l'année si fier où j'ai connu membres de
l'aïe sefyu la fin de la session c'était
aussi le drame oui oui la saison c'était
avant c'était avant le parti socialiste
j'ai connu des moments pour un militant
qui à la fois dans son dans son
engagement c'était des moments
extrêmement douloureux il y avait un
mollet de fer qui se bagarraient cet
arrêt set c'était aussi
aussi décourageant que ce que l'on voit
maintenant et donc la gauche elle
restera parce que elle a une philosophie
une idéologie une envie de de fraternité
d'humanité donc ça ça restera b le parti
socialiste et d'autres sont sûrement à
reconstruire je voudrais vous interrogez
maintenant sur un sondage un sondage
mené par l'institut ifop pour le
magazine l'étudiant qui place alain
juppé comme candidat des étudiants
candidats favoris des étudiants 40 % des
interrogés disent que c'est le maire de
bordeaux qui répond le plus à leurs
attentes par contre ils sont 45% à dire
qu'ils n'iront pas voter un chiffre
forcément inquiétant à quelques mois de
l'élection nous sommes allés demander
l'avis aux étudiants de l'université de
versailles saint quentin ce qu'il
comptait faire écouter leurs réponse
je ne sais pas encore trop renseigner
parce que j'ai
juste d'avoir 18 ans mais je compte
aller voter c'est la direction de notre
pays et c'est important de
d'y contribuer même si c'est pas
forcément
même si un candidat ne remplit pas
entièrement à nos attentes pour moi une
sorte de caste qui s'est créé dans la
classe politique qui s'est vraiment
éloigné en gros de ce que nous on attend
une personnage politique qui nous parle
et pour le coup n'y a personne qui qui
semble me représenter en tout cas en ce
moment il ya personne oui je compte
aller voter et je compte aller voter
blanc tout simplement vous commencerez à
m'intéresser vraiment un tout petit peu
plus tard parce que là mais concours
vont arriver du coup j'ai pas vraiment
le temps oui oui un candidat qui me qui
répond à mes attentes
pour les présidentielles de 2017 et
oui je compte bien évidemment les voter
oui on le voit dans ce dans ce micro
trottoir guy malandain les étudiants ne
savent pas trop fermés y en a qui vont
voter d'autres non ils ne savent pas
vraiment pour qui en tout cas le sondage
10 45 % des étudiants qui ne vont pas se
déplacer dans les urnes c'est ça en fait
le problème principal ce sont ce sont
les jeunes c'est l'avenir du pays
comment comment on fait pour les ramener
aux urnes et je crois que
je vais choquer en disant simple je
crois que les
jeux le 18e dans la droite et la gauche
ce sont des réalités philosophiques
sociologiques et cetera très bien je
crois que les partis républicains je
parle pas des extrêmes je parle des
partis républicains qui ont les idées de
droite sont pas les miennes et les
partis républicains qui ont aidé gauche
y sont les mythes doit s'interroger sur
quelle est leur relation à la population
si la moitié des jeunes gens et de
jeunes filles qui sont aujourd'hui
universitaires sont dans cette situation
c'est parce que en tant que parti un
côté comme de l'autre moi je donne pas
le clac clac et d'autres donnent deux
claques à personne je fais un constat
c'est parce que ce que je suis ce que je
représente mon action mais dire mais
positionnement ma façon d'être ma
relation quotidienne avec la population
et avec les réalités de vie des gens ne
sont pas ressenties comme élément
positif or le rôle des partis politiques
c'est porter des réponses à des réalités
et et un projet pour le devenir et jeu
je le sens pas d'ailleurs est peut-être
venir ça va me la déviance on l'espère
on laisse un parti politique qui
organise le premier tour de la primaire
ce dimanche c'est forcément la droite et
le centre et pour ceux qui souhaitent
aller voter ils peuvent chercher le
bureau de vote le plus proche de chez
eux sur
www.premiere.fr point org toujours en
politique locale cette fois ci cette
semaine se tenait l'élection du nouveau
maire à guyancourt les élus ont voté
pour marie-christine le tarnec pour
succéder à françois de ligne et celui ci
était à la tête de la commune depuis
2002 elle les précisions et les détails
avec ce reportage
26 voix pour 4 blanc et 2 contres
marie-christine le tarnec est depuis
mardi 15 novembre la nouvelle maire
socialiste de guyancourt l'ancienne élue
en charge notamment des finances succède
à françois de ligne et qu'ils avaient
décidé début octobre de passer le relais
après 14 ans à la tête de la commune ému
au moment de prendre la parole françois
de ligne et restera tout de même
conseiller municipal et communautaire
jusqu'en 2020 mes premiers mots c'est
pour dire que j'ai effectivement
beaucoup d'émotion c'est un passage de
relais un passage de relais qui se passe
bien comme je l'avais dit je reste dans
l'équipe je resterai aussi conseiller
communautaire mais vous le voyez ma
christine mènera le projet de ville avec
une équipe dynamique je serai jusqu'à
2020 dans cette équipe et c'est donc
avec beaucoup de sérénité que je peux
participer à
ces mois qu'ils sont et ses années qui
sont devant nous pour l'occasion benoît
hamon député ps et catherine tasca
sénatrice socialiste avait fait le
déplacement plus d'une centaine
d'habitants également des habitants que
la nouvelle maire a tenu à rassurer son
mandat sera celui de la continuité j'ai
été élu sur une liste depuis 2014 donc
maintenant je suis maire effectivement
en milieu du mandat mais j'ai participé
à la liste de françois de ligne et on a
été élu pour un mandat effectivement de
6 ans avec un projet de ville et je vais
respecter les engagements qui ont été
pris devant les aiglons pour toi et on
va les tenir l'opposition municipale
elle a tenu à saluer l'engagement de
françois de ligne et durant 14 ans
l'élection d'un nouveau maire signifie
également de nouvelles relations avec la
majorité c'est évident que cette
démission doit aussi nous permettre de
relancer de relancer les échanges de
relancer les discussions avec avec
l'exécutif je proposerai à
marie-christine le tarnec peut-être de
se voir afin de pouvoir discuter en
effet 2
et bien de les quatre années qui
viendront jusqu'en 2020 marie-christine
le tarnec devra également composer avec
quelques remous au sein de sa majorité
municipale les quatre élus écologistes
n'ont ainsi pas pris part au vote lors
de son élection
dit malandain très rapidement une
réaction très rapide sur sur le départ
de françois de ligne ça a été un
camarade de combat politique on va dire
pendant des années tout tout à fait ça a
été un bon collègue donc moi j'ai connu
roland à dos françois d'heuliez de très
près ce kit est élu en même temps
d'ailleurs dedans non mais doué deux
amis qu'on fait un travail formidable
sur la ville de guyancourt et donc le
même le même l'espoir et où aucun doute
un sera fait avec eux le maire qui a été
élue la semaine dernière une petite
question peut être sûr peut-être votre
succession à vous est ce que vous vous
aussi vous envisagez forcément de passer
la main où vous irez jusqu'en 2020 au
bout de votre mandat c'est sûr à qui
sait combien de temps je vais pouvoir
survivre tout ça non pour l'instant
l'engagement que j'ai pris je suis
sérieux là le remisage mans que j'ai
pris et de faire mon mandat et saufs en
ainsi donc personne ne peut prévoir dans
sa vie je finirai demande à voir après
on en rediscutera on referme ce 7,8
hebdo avec la ville de coignières qui
organisait jeudi 17 novembre son
traditionnel au forum de recrutement 35
sociétés étaient présentes le groupe
thales notamment des grands groupes de
distribution mais aussi des
représentants du secteur des services à
la personne près de 800 personnes sont
venues présenter leur candidature on
écoute à ce propos le maire de la ville
ça fait maintenant
plus de 13 ans donc nous nous organisons
cet événement il me semble très très
important de provoquer la rencontre
entre l'entreprise le commerce et puis
le demandeur d'emploi bien sûr ces taxes
est essentiel c'est une obligation tout
de même morale d'aider les demandeurs
d'emploi parce que nous sommes dans une
situation tout de même mais maintenant
qu'ils demandent que tout le monde se
met à l'ouvragé pour provoquer pour
provoquer les rencontres pour donner de
l'emploi à tous
c'est la fin de ce set 8 hebdo merci guy
maddin de nous avoir aspiré nié pendant
cette demi heure pour vos réponses je
rappelle bien sûr que vous êtes le maire
socialiste de trappes en yvelines merci
à vous aussi de nous avoir suivis bon
week-end à tous et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]